all right everyone it's time to continue
with the green-screen competition we got
a lot I've got we got so much [ __ ]
weird [ __ ] I forgot to turn on my life I
guess the lightning so good I don't hey
I don't need it I look sparkly and shiny
and beautiful and perfect complex skin
anyway thank you very me let's keep
watching the green-screen competition
submissions this is creepy man
[Music]
that's the TV show I want to watch one
Puetz man alright alright alright I want
to have my own anime so bad why America
should be Sweden man [ __ ] good [ __ ]
man damn Malcolm really it just thank
you for everyone else submitting but
this one was clearly the best one Jesus
Christ hey if I meet Zoey
Jesus thumb now is that Zoey from left
for dead
what the hell that doesn't even make any
[ __ ] sense take it back that was the
winner
[Music]
to be fair what was I expecting honestly
I don't know
Oh God attack on Titan attack on peds
attack on pad this go it's gonna be good
I'm so sorry
it didn't mean anything bad I was just
so [ __ ] was so filthy Frank with
PewDiePie [ __ ] that looks legit man when
the [ __ ] you it's your boy PewDiePie
you want war you can have it I mean I
pay to watch it coming this never just
like Kingdom Hearts 3 huh what the [ __ ]
oh hello I need to start watching Game
of Thrones I'm so sorry
didn't be the hoping bad how do you
think I got this many cents
no no verify now hey another matrix yes
nice lip-sync oh no it's stealing and
Malcolm coming over the third guys
so again
you do anything so long as superimpose
all this [ __ ] man
oh whoa holy [ __ ] that was so good that
was so [ __ ] yet Thank You Lourdes
George Lucas Dimas that Edgar shot these
are so creative I love it it's so much
fun to go through these
[Laughter]
[Music]
now you know how to defeat me just throw
a Japanese cream mask in my face that
sounds weird but it's true this is what
I really kicked you out it's not because
I'm a poly do you accept that what can I
say
you still kicked me out though if I
chase is marketplace
[Music]
[Laughter]
I wanted to be longer oh no it's an MMD
of Finance of Freddie's oh it's my laser
stop now it makes such awesome memories
like a breath ugh [ __ ] oh he's coming
he's coming
[Music]
that's a good [ __ ] they say the words
jump-scare of all is pretty pies is
[Music]
what
holy [ __ ] the amount of editing that
would go into this oh yeah so some of
you flat-out stole other people's
submissions like that's not cool we we
know if you're pulling that [ __ ] you get
banned for it alright so have fun what
the [ __ ] no no no furry [ __ ] got stopped
nope
goddammit then The Lion King soundtrack
in the back that's bad that's why would
you think of this okay
you don't win the competition oh my gosh
kdrama
I love kdrama yeah that's pretty good
space Lyman man it's it's not even funny
but it's funny great use of three
seconds I gotta say yep you did it three
seconds that takes that takes Talent man
what are you going to be doing you want
to see magic trick okay I love a mystery
go ahead and do what it is you do I can
fly my god
[Laughter]
beauty 5 vs. PewDiePie oh my lord
so the bride it's the Brighton Beach a
hey oh oh oh
PT five wins oh it's got a combo it's
got a camera round tip for [ __ ] sake
no no it was great until this point
within a matter like the footage that we
gave was so [ __ ] and that they saved the
kiddies managed to do that out of that
is that's pretty [ __ ] impressive man
okay that's really good
what if I mean that I'd see oh this [ __ ]
oh oh yeah nice
holy [ __ ] Oh for [ __ ] sake
dude that was [ __ ] awesome
a spicy meme indeed I loved every single
one of these is so fun thank you so much
for submitting to the green-screen
content test next one will be the meme
contest the PewDiePie meme contest it
should be in [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm
sure length to that is in description
thank you so much for watching and thank
you so much for submitting and as always
bros I know you will do some brows that
is true he just keeps me in the class
what is this I don't know honestly Oh
Oh what is this oh my god what the hell